josh allen set to join us and the
buffalo bills quarterback
he is joining us on behalf of as i get
my paperwork here promoting his cereal
josh's jacks with the proceeds
benefiting the children hospital
in buffalo first place in the afc west
they won sunday against the jets they
got the patriots
uh coming up this weekend and uh kind
enough to join us with uh
an interesting sweatshirt what's it say
on the front of your uh
sweatshirt there uh this
says talentless
okay okay why
it's it's a brand uh scott disick i
don't know he's got a it's his brand
i like their their stuff it wasn't like
a play on anything
i don't know i just i like the brand oh
wait scott from the
kardashians that's right yeah
have you met him no never i just
i'm not gonna lie to you i was on
instagram one day and it this ad popped
up and it was targeted obviously for me
and i thought it was a cool brand and
i bought one sweatshirt and the
sweatshirts were so comfortable i ended
up buying like
six more of them so i wear them all the
time
but you you're not talentless
no no not at all
is is that your is that the buffalo
bills
facility you're in or are you at home no
i'm in my house right now
what's the coolest thing in your house
um i've got my elvis poster up here
okay big elvis fan um coolest thing in
my house i don't i don't have many
cool things uh if you will
um i don't i don't buy a whole lot of
things so
that that's that's my most prized
possession have you got my idaho potato
ball mvp downstairs too so have you been
to graceland
never actually been to graceland oh so i
need to get down there
you got to do the whole tour man if you
love elvis you go to
on that tour it's awesome
yeah that's that's that's on the bucket
list for sure uh
so are you an mvp candidate how do you
react when you hear that
um i mean i'm just trying to do my job
to be honest
and be the best quarterback the best
teammate that i could be for the buffalo
bills um
if that like i said has me thrown for
300 yards and five touchdowns and
throwing for 100 yards and
zero touchdowns whatever the case may be
to put us in position to win a football
game that's that's what i'm for so
i really don't care about any of the
other accolades but
being in that contention means our
team's winning and we're doing what
we're supposed to do so i'm all for it
do you play with a chip on your shoulder
yeah yeah absolutely and i think that it
goes back to
zero recruit there's zero offers out of
high school and one out of
junior college um and then just kind of
being nitpicked and picked apart by
everybody it seems like in the media but
i really don't i tried trying my best to
not really pay attention to all that
stuff
and like i said focus on being the best
that i can be and um
you know i'm a realist and uh
you know i acknowledge that the flaws in
my game and me trying to get better and
trying to work on these flaws and
you know being self-aware in my opinion
is one of the greatest traits that you
can have especially as a leader of a
football team
what's your biggest flaw i mean i think
that
you know they're early on just being the
home run first mentality
you know uh putting myself in the ball
in harm's way
um too early or you know two too often
and i think i've kind of toned back on
that and i've had a lot of help along
the way and been able to work on my
mechanics um
one but two also times up with that with
uh you know the knowledge of the game
and knowledge of our offense and
um you know i think in one area this
this offseason i've gotten really good
at is
knowing where i'm protected uh knowing
where um
my eyes need to go you know i have to
snap you know trying to decipher what a
defense is doing and then just trying to
find the right answer
do you avoid the hits enough
not enough no um and i need to
you know going back to this last game
there's a couple i probably could have
just slid
but um something about you know
putting my body on the line for for my
team no no
josh josh no i know i know
no no what would your mom say if we lost
you like you can't do that
you slide i know
and i get the best abilities
availability and i understand that it
just
i've learned i slid once last game i
slid twice the game before
so i'm definitely keeping a tally of how
many times i'm sliding but uh
if it's third down if it's fourth down i
got to put my body in line to go get it
i'm going to go do it you were a
baseball player you know how to slide
come on i know
i was more of a picture though you still
know how to slide
yeah you still don't have what's what's
the worst yelling
that you've got from coach mcdermott
like the worst airing out
i i coach mcdermott he's more kind of a
defensive minded head coach so he's
he just trying to tries to give me
knowledge
as far as defensive terminology and
scheme goes
coach dabo was uh it was my first year
[Laughter]
and we were running just a simple spot
concept it was a flat a little stick
route in the corner route
and we were in the red zone and the flat
popped free right away
in our read it is bottom up you read it
low to high low to high
and uh my buddy austin pro was running
the corner route and
i tried to stick in a back shoulder and
didn't work out and
i mean in my headset immediately i can
hear the table going off
i look over to the side he's beat red
and i mean
he let me have it for a good five
minutes and then also he calmed down and
he starts thinking about it again he
gets even more angry but
it's just one of those times where like
i knew i knew i was wrong and there's
nothing i can say to you that's going to
make you feel better
um except go up the next time and read a
bottom up
you can't turn the volume down in your
helmet
no unfortunately not and you've got to
eat like
those are the situations where you just
kind of have to trust your equipment
manager and your equipment staff to be
like
i hope you guys didn't turn this too
loud because sometimes it is
like kind of painful when he's screaming
at you so um
that that was a long time ago and you
know he hasn't had much to scream about
in the last couple years so that's
that's been good it's josh allen the
bill's quarterback what was your welcome
to the nfl moment
um i mean i think
you know i was playing the chargers
that's my first start i think just
kind of the boat racing that they put on
us that game the blitz the presser
um you know melvin ingram and bosa got
after me a couple times
i think darwin james hit me pretty good
um but i did shake off one of his
tackles but
i think it was that game just being like
this this is fast because i mean i was
thrown into the
the mix the week prior at half right
after halftime
against baltimore and uh like i said it
was just going into my first start i was
so excited for it and like things were
just
i mean i heard bullets flying by my head
i was just like oh my god like
i gotta be in tune and ready to go you
know and it was just kind of eye-opening
that we go up next week and we play
minnesota at minnesota we're 20-point
underdogs and uh we come out and we
kind of shocked the world there so that
was one of those those cool moments
does your family still have the farm
yeah yeah they do and uh so we're
we're traditionally a row crop so we do
cantaloupe cotton and wheat
but me and my dad actually we purchased
about 100
acres worth of pistachio trees you're
gonna start planting these probably in
march so
um that's something i'm really excited
about is it tough for being a farmer or
playing quarterback in the nfl
farming for you sure there's just so
many elements
you can't control the weather that's
like one thing farming needs you need
sunshine you need a lot of rain and uh
central california doesn't seem to get
too much of the rain sometimes so
it's very hectic and it's something you
know i saw my dad struggle with and be
super smart about
throughout my years and he was always my
biggest role model with just his work
ethic and
you know what he would do to provide for
our family so
you know football you just gotta make
the right decisions and make the right
throws without trying to
take too many hits give me the
quarterback you think would be the worst
farmer
oh
in the league or on our team in the
league
let's see i think herbert would be a
pretty good farmer because he's
he's a marine biologist right and i
think he would kind of get some of that
stuff so
um i don't know about that um
maybe nick foles i don't know
he doesn't look like he wants to get his
hands dirty or what
no he's just i don't know he's just uh
well wait how do you think how do you
think brady would do how do you think
brady would do on the farm
there josh i don't know i don't know
he's he's kind of old-timey he
i think he gets a lot of things um i
just
you know what i take back nick you know
he's got a great relationship with god
and
you know the rain would come from i mean
he'd be running
all sorts of places for him
[Laughter]
it would rain 40 days and 40 nights josh
exactly exactly so i'd take that back
he'd probably be the best one
um yeah i don't know
i don't know no brady would be farming
he'd have kale
he'd have kale and he'd probably have
avocados and yeah
doing the smart and nutritional plants
and he would even be yelling at the
cantaloupe
chewing it out yeah i'm going with sam
um you know sam he's a socal kid he's a
beachy guy
i've seen i don't know if he'd survive
on the farm sam darnold wouldn't yeah
how often do you talk to sam
we talk pretty often probably at least
once or twice a week
um whether it's personal texts
if it's instagram direct messages with
our group chats
if it's call of duty um sometimes we get
online and play video games with each
other
so it's it's pretty often i love what
you're doing with this cereal tell
tell my audience what you're doing and
who it's benefiting
yeah so josh's jacks um you know thanks
to plbs
e you know it's in a sports
entertainment group that kind of allowed
me to to go out and get a serial
um but it's available at tops and
wegmans and in
majority pers you know portion of the
proceeds go to
shy children's hospital and i've been
working with osha since i first got here
um three years ago and um you know i'm
able to kind of go in and
talk with these kids and you know
unfortunately throughout coronavirus
it's all been virtual but you know it's
something special to my heart that
this cereal benefits such a good cause
and it it can really help
um you know fund this hospital with you
know
necessities that they need you know
especially in trying times like this so
it's been awesome and
i'm really looking forward to continuing
my relationship with um
shai christian hospital yeah the serial
is josh
uh jack's j a q posture fiest proceeds
benefiting the children's hospital
in buffalo i was just thinking about
this with the pistachios
when you go to market you just call them
josh's nuts
trust me we've thought about that yeah
yeah
i mean come on who doesn't want josh's
nuts
you're speechless i don't know
[Laughter]
you're going to be a mogul you're going
to be a tycoon uh hey it's great to talk
to you congrats on your success thanks
for being a good sport
and uh good luck i appreciate you thanks
for having me on dan
josh allen